I like to start with the question really
sort of the genesis of these films and
will the electoral start with you
I understand you you saw a play called
the broken circle breakdown right the
title of the play was actually the
broken circle breakdown featuring the
cover-ups of Alabama mouthful and yeah a
beautiful play made by your own helmet
who's the male lead of the movie he's a
great actor and playwright and filmmaker
actually he made he made he made a film
too and you'd work with him before yeah
the film yeah movies and I saw it I
loved it I went to see it again I said
it's not possible to turn this into a
movie it's great but I'm not gonna do it
and then it kept coming back to me so I
think six months later the producer and
I were actually we spent like a week
somewhere in France in Avignon in the
house and I was thinking about what my
next movie should be and then I wrote
you on an email like could you send me
or the text of your theater play and
then Dirk hadn't hadn't seen the play
but we both read it again and I listened
to clips on YouTube of the songs that
featured in the theater play and I
started crying again and crying and and
and dirt thought it was fantastic to
just on the basis of the text and we
said well we'll go for it
we'll try and do it you have no idea how
but we'll try and make it work in and
then you adapted the two of you adapt a
screenplay from from the play because it
must be much different those of you who
have haven't seen it broken circle
breakdown has incredible transitions but
they're not the obvious ones it's at
first blush you're not quite sure where
where you are you actually do catch on
immediately but it's it goes from
several different time time periods
without a single indication that you're
that you're moving that you're moving in
moving times
that's something that came about you
know that the process to to get to that
in the end took that was you know that
was making a movie it took two and a
half years to get to that and we when we
started working on the screenplay
which I didn't adapt with you hon but
with another screenwriter Carlos we we
always knew that we were gonna have to
play with time because because the
theater play you know in a way it worked
like that too but it wasn't it was just
two people talking and and and it was
actually a bluegrass concert and and in
between the songs they were they would
talk to the audience and tell their
story but you knew very quickly that it
was about an ex couple who had lost a
kid and and so it was it was very
quickly very emotional I start I started
crying after 20 minutes and just didn't
stop and in order to you know that
experience was just so overwhelming that
I thought that the movie should should
try and reach that too
or that that theater play I always you
know it was always like the big that
experience I had was always like the big
inspiration we have to get to death to
what I experienced the first time I saw
it so when we started writing we we
developed different storylines we went
back and forth but we redid everything
in editing because it wasn't working the
way we wanted it and it and we forgot
about the screenplay and just nakulan
was the editor he at some point just
said let's forget about the screenplay
and start over and that you know those
last weeks of editing where we
discovered that were very very magical
receive and and with you how did this
film come about I understand it it's
based on on a book he wrote at the
beginning no I I finished writing a book
and I went to the shooting and
work with with few Khmer Rouge
cinematographer and I would like just to
know how the totally tourism government
produced their own propaganda how they
vehicle the ideology and I walk with
these rules in a matter refer for more
than one day and half and I remember I
never called back to my home because I
leave my home seen in 75 when the Khmer
will come to power and I have never back
there again because when we leave the
home there are no mirrors
my parent with my pram and now it was
impossible for me to go back home alone
so but I decide at this time had to go
back to the home but I did did not
recognize my home and it's a transformed
to the brother with game Ling Cara okay
so I did talk to my team I talk to my
team that maybe we can construct a model
because I remember very well what it
look like
so we start to build a model but we are
not a Kotak you know we the window is
too big
etc so I asked my assistant please
produce for me a figurine represent a
little boy as why like I was when I was
13 and we can't build a home around this
little boy and one of my assistants
start to scold
he asked me we won it in wood or stone
you know in clay like we were young you
know we have not toy but we have clay in
the river and we produce figurine and we
invent story with that and he start to
produce to skirt first figurine
and it's was amazing is expressive and
that I remember that I'm how if we link
that what I can say it it's like when
you look at one Miro or Picasso school
you know it's something very pure it's
looked like innocence of childhood
something like that and I think I can
use it because it's a about a story of
thirteen years old boy so I decide to
change the idea of the film and to start
to make a film with clay figurine but
it's a little bit difficult to explain
to your partner you know you know you
start a film with figurine people ask me
it will move you have your name it
animated you know no they will stay
fixed like they represent our soul
cetera I know you can develop a lot of
idea around that but it's still
difficult to make 1/2 a meter figurine
that do not move what we are in the time
of gravity no big picture nothing
remarkable remarkable technically and
said what maybe we have to come back
with our hand to produce something with
clay what and ride with the Sun like the
element of life that make you live and
maybe with that you can make a film or
some story about genocide I try to make
a fiction you know but it's not possible
for me
maybe it's much more easier for people
who did not live directly genocide to
direct actor/actress how to die in
genocide how to kill but it seemed to me
a little bit hard for people who live
directly with genocide
but with this so I try for many years to
final form that can permit me to to tell
the story and and the clay is it's good
because after now after to film he
travel with me a little bit and maybe he
will be back to the clay to the water to
dust there's no dress just one soul who
live with us forever
those of you who haven't seen the film
it it's absolutely fascinating that it
truly is made with clay figures who
represent with ease family against
against archival footage of the
atrocities of the Khmer Rouge and it is
it is a harrowing in that it is both
incredibly emotional and yet your
distance from it it's not the same thing
as watching a documentary or a
reenactment so if if there is such a
thing you're able to actually think
about what's going on and what what's
being done it's it's really quite
remarkable I couldn't agree more the
most moving picture I've seen in many
many years amazing film definitely I can
just see me going into a studio heads
office and proposing a film with clay
figures that don't move and and and your
film where where does it stem from well
I tried raising that over here took
about 15 minutes so it was like that did
you actually think of making it in
English I did one phone call because I
thought you've got some great isolated
cities surrounded by trees and some
great actors over here and I wanted to
do that and my agent said are you crazy
you can't convince any bankers over here
that and about this topic you won't be
able to raise $1 and so we went back to
Denmark and I'm really happy with did
that I think it's found its own purity
back home I'm glad you did - yeah the
whole thing started with my shrink
or a guy to become my shrink he knocked
my door I had done a film many many
years ago the celebration which was it
were you about 17 yeah
it's about 68 years ago no it was about
a man who had his father's 60th birthday
conveys the truth of the child abused
his father committed to him throughout
his life wonderful birthday party and
and and after that film a lot of people
wanted me to do other movies like every
day I went to do shopping or something
someone had came over and said I just
knocked down my dad and you got to make
that movie or you know horrible stories
they wanted me to make and one of those
nights a guy knocks my door and he says
did you do the celebration and I said
yes well then there's another film you
have to do fine there's these cases
about children and added memory he
talked about a thing called he
considered the thought a virus how a
thought a wrong thought possibly can
spread and it was all very fascinating
but at that time I had enough of the
celebration so I put away these files
didn't read them and it took me about
eight years and then I needed a shrink
and I thought I'll walk down the road
and talk to him and I our politeness I
read these cases and and I was
profoundly shocked and moved by it one
of the first thing I read was that
eighteen different kids hadn't had been
interrogated and had given testimony
about a basement I've given the same
precise description about description
about the colors of the wall all the
details and the police goes to this
house to do a search of this place and
there is no basement it's all a
collective fantasy and I was like I have
to dig into this and I called Tobias
Lynn home
the greatest writer of all times and and
and he was on to it immediately and then
we started it it would at what point did
you consider making it as as an American
film once you had a finished script or
just as an idea just as an idea then
mark is a great great country I love it
but it's very tiny and can feel very
close to phobic and I had an urge to get
out but I'm still really happy that we
went back it seems like when we dig into
our own little backyard that less is
more things grow bigger that way it's
interesting an American audience would
have said why did not the Mads Mikkelsen
character get a lawyer involved right
away I knew that anyhow that that
question arrived that and what happened
to the dog is very right right we've got
it we're very concerned about the dog
there it's got it's got it's got eight
puppies now but but I saw a response to
the lawyer question you said that had he
gotten a lawyer in Denmark that would
have told everybody that he was guilty
totally we just don't do that too much
we can go to a hospital and there's no
lawyers
Paulo Paulo last night said he set out
to make a film about everything and he
ended up making a film about nothing but
you better explain that because I think
it's one of the most ambitious films
I've ever seen yeah because at the
beginning that the genesis of the movie
started 20 years ago when I when went to
Rome to work and I started to gather
materials about everything I saw of
different respect my city Naples so I
started to gather materials about
Vatican about television world some
people in the parties and I put on my
not book many things about people that
was were unbearable insupportable and
that I ate but then when I went later
when I went back to I slowly I found out
that the things and the people that I
hated something of interesting and so I
started to think about the movie where
the the pain and the misery of the human
being will be a resource for themselves
and for everybody and so I get as many
many materials in the years and for this
reason it started to be a movie about
everything because there was so many
things that it was a movie about
everything and but all those things were
stupid and useless things
so we me and micro writer we found out
suddenly that it was exactly the
opposite it was a movie about I think
that flopper called the nothing the
the ways of time the chat between the
people the history of lava that start
but they died soon after and so about
all these things we do to do a movie but
only after we had the idea of a
character a journalist that has the
chance to go everywhere and in in all
this context and that's it let me ask
you what what has the reaction been in
Italy to the film because if you it
certainly doesn't
as many wonderful things as it says
about modern-day Italy
it doesn't necessarily paint a rosy
picture of where the Italian spirit is
today yeah there is a gap of
communication between me and some people
in Italy because they don't understand
that I love that people and so I think
that they are good people
and some people believe that this is not
true that I I do a picture of a hitter
II like something of bed and decadent
but I believe exactly the opposite that
the decadence and the deckhands could be
a beautiful thing
yes that's that's my idea so we have a
problem of communication but and then
some people recognize themselves and so
they were a little bit they didn't like
this thing but at the same time who was
not inside the movie was disappointed
because they who loved to stay in the
Italian people is not easy to satisfy
I believe in accepting the Golden Globe
you you recognized
was it you're you're crazy and beautiful
country yes honey but what about you
where where does Omar come from actually
thank you Kevin for the nice
introduction but it really started also
after paradise now even you are nominee
you will get a lot of offers from
Hollywood a lot of scripts and they will
put you in the luxury hotels with a
swimming pool and I felt immediately
like Barton Fink exact what a lot of
money with no any with writer blog and
one night I panicked
after I think three four years and truly
panicked in Los Angeles started here in
Los Angeles I was in a you know Lowe's
hotel with us you know on the swimming
pool that night and then when went to
bed and in the night I panicked panicked
like I couldn't I was so scared and
sweating then I I asked myself why I am
NOT doing good things here and the
answer was because whatever we do here
it's mostly artificial not coming from
real life and I really wanted to do
something from my own experience and I
remember like one of my traumatic
experience was when i when i was doing
paradise now i felt that i believed that
there was a traitor inside my crew and
if you think there was a traitor like
inside your crew spying on you you
become insane because you don't know who
it is and you start to suspect everybody
including yourself because you said you
think maybe my my phone is backed of my
hotel room I start to register myself in
one room and to sleep in another room
insane and this idea I just wanted to
translate it in a
on the vessel way and it was the best
way is love because in love we all
recognize this paranoia feeling because
when you are in love and insecure you
start to suspect your lover in any like
if she will get any SMS you will think
oh my god is a man behind this SMS and
then with this like I start to write at
four o'clock in the morning in LA in LA
when I wake up in panic and that 8
o'clock was the structure former done
and for he for our four days later was
the whole script done and usually I say
I send the scripts to my script to gem
Seamus a friend of mine and they trust
them and always he will send back after
one month 30 pages of notes and I was
expecting the same you know to develop
the script and then for the first time
he will call me James Seamus and he will
say to whom I should call speak to your
lawyer or your agent and I said what
about the notes and he said no notes we
will do this movie I said no no I don't
want to be involved anymore with the
Hollywood system because it will give if
I will do it through the whole it sees
the Hollywood system I will be stuck
again
and you know that indie and he said you
are right but I will help you trace the
money and and we start to you know to do
it I you know we did it by our own we
approached well iterator friend of mine
an actor and I want him to be in the
movie and after he read the script he
said okay I'm gonna help you with
raising the money his brothers and
anchor investors they put most of the
money and they found from friends and
family other the rest of the two million
and so we did
I would like to talk about the casting
process because all five of these movies
and no surprise are beautifully cast
there there's not a false note in them
and a lot of them there are unseasoned
actors and probably actors acting in a
film for the first time and several of
you have have children
Felix how did you go about it you have a
play that you've seen starring the man
who who wrote it and I'm assuming that
there was no question about that that
Jonah was always going to play that part
how did you go about casting the other
parts of other key parts including the
band and then also you have a remarkable
remarkable young girl who I believe is
five versus five or six and in the film
who not only is a wonderful really
inspired actress but she has to play
some very difficult you know medical
scenes how how did you go about it well
I saw the play and Johan was great and
the actors who played in the play was
great too but when I started writing I I
felt that I wanted to do auditions that
I wasn't sure if if she should play I
think my fantasy about this character
changed but and so after writing the
first draft after a couple of months we
I did auditions and and and saw great
actresses they all had to perform two
songs and and do a couple of scenes with
Johan he was there and then the last
actress to show up was feeling and and
she she had worked with Derek she was
working with their con TV series she's
the most famous actress in Belgium so it
was no surprise that that I asked her
and she's also you know she was really
good in that series so I really wanted
to see her and before you know before
she came I was doubting maybe this
factors maybe this actress would be
better and I was doubting and then she
came along and and and she just nailed
it I mean it was the magic was there she
and Johann like I mean I I start a spark
I was moved it was magical and but
especially because at some point we were
doing the scene a very emotional scene
in the film where the couple starts to
blame one another after the death of the
child so we were doing that scene in the
audition not an easy scene and she she
had a hard time getting into it she felt
I thought it was really good but she
felt and then Johann said if you if you
wanna you know use me use me
so she we do another take and she starts
hitting him and more and more and and
then he he I mean it became a little
violent actually and then okay and after
that she she went into the scene again
and it was it was great so it was it was
a remarkable experience for Johan both
Johan and me and we you know we were
actually a little scared of her because
of that and not just a heading but you
know this this thing she brought along I
think you know it it it she added a
darkness to this character that which in
which this character needed I did I mean
it wasn't written she really brought it
along there I believe that this woman
could commit suicide
that she could be that disappointed in
life to do it so that was the reason why
she had to do it and and to talk about
the little girl you know we I think we
were really afraid of this how to deal
with this and deal with the parents you
know asking parents
- for their daughter to play a girl that
dies that dies of cancer so it was it
was weird I felt were very weird about
so we had a hundred little girls come by
I think that that audition then we at
some point we chose a seven or eight and
then we decided to work a couple of
weeks with them just have them coming
and and see how they come you know if
they would get better and then also we
started like talking to the parents
telling them what the story was about
and and asking the parents to you know
to think about if they would be okay
with it and to talk with the kid too and
to read the script and so that was a
great experience because I felt that
once you started talking about it it
made it very very easy and none of the
parents were like had a problem with it
taught at some point because they were
wondering how would you do the baldhead
well we'll probably do makeup and it you
know it became something fun just by
talking about it and and and now who
actually got the role she came back like
six weeks in a row and she got better
every time she wasn't the most she was a
little bit shy in the beginning but she
got better every time and that's why we
taught at some point we you know she has
to be it because she her tension span
got better she was interested she had
fun and that's why you know we chose to
work with her and the you know the crazy
thing was once I had chosen her and I
brought her together with Johanna and
Vila immediately they bonded and like
became a family and and on set you know
it it wasn't usually a lot of times it
wasn't even me directing was just you on
and viola because they were with her in
the shot and they would tell her a
little more it is a little more that so
it was amazing and in the band members
were they the same band men members who
were in the in the play actually there's
only the violent player who was uh who
was in the play and in the in the movie
and it was also the musician so we the
musicians musicians were changed we
brought in another
guy his name is Bjorn Alex only he'd
been playing bluegrass music since he
was 15 years old and he brought a great
authenticity to the to the music and he
recorded the music together with Johanna
and Valen they saw their own songs and
he brought along his musicians and the
violin player like I said but then we
for the movie we casted actors to play
the musicians because because they look
better I guess I was going to ask you
did you cast actors who could did you go
for actors and then find out who could
who the musicians were there or or the
other way around yeah I did some of the
auditions and the people I asked I
realized very quickly that a lot of them
could play music and then like the guy
who plays the mandolin he plays little
guitar and very quickly he was like
playing it and loving it
the guy who plays the dobro - he's he's
an actor but also he plays a little bit
of guitar and only the guitar player he
did you know he did a really bad job but
you only have these shots until here and
then we had like takes from a real
guitar player so it it we made it work
that way so now I understand this the
music from this this film is absolutely
extraordinary American bluegrass and I
understand it's the top-selling music
soundtrack of a film in in in Belgium
yeah we beat Titanic
yeah it's amazing how it took off and
yeah and this band you know with Johanna
vila dare they last year they toured all
year they did summer festivals and when
we go back they will do another tour of
30 shows fantastic pretty talking to you
about casting is is a completely
different subject since you have no
actors in your in your film you have a
narrator a very seductive narrator who
is is completely unsettling because
sometimes he's very matter-of-fact about
some of the most horrendous incidences
how did you cast him why didn't you use
your own voice and very importantly why
why is it in French it's in French at
his first film that we write the text in
French first because it's like a homage
to my father and to your father
yeah my father he spoke French fluently
and he liked very much to French poetry
and when do you understand he understood
that the Khmer Rouge will destroy
everything did the facts of the genocide
you know is not only killing people but
they destroy their dignity first and
their identity and so when he understand
that the Khmer Rouge proceeded to
eliminate everything he started to speak
French and to tell them because it's
mean that you know it difficile
difficult to resist because you were
approached you're the Jews hunger as a
weapon were deported so
he find the solution to find something
to resist again this regime so he start
to speak the French because it's
knowledge that is belong to him you
cannot you can maybe kill him but not
his so not his imagination not the
poetry so it you think it's a strong
lesson for me how to resist even by
silence and we must to raise this
because you know if people said that
history don't repeat but I repeat every
time see maybe tomorrow
Russian tank we go to crane don't
remember it's happened today now and
remember people in Venezuela how they
fight now so we are here to like a
mirror you know like something of coke
we make film it's very subjective but we
are here also to transmit a message to
tell the people that you know you must
do stand-up gym but to resist and we
like the community on transmitter to
transmit transmit the message that those
people who died sent to the next
generation we artists we like distance
method with we must do the transmission
so I find I try to have to have some
artists to tell it in French but at the
end I asked my friend roundel Duke who
is a mathematician but he's also yeah
but he was not so he liked very much to
play after but he's a very very highly
well mathematician he teach in the very
great school in Paris but so I asked him
you know tell it and put nothing inside
words no sentiment
nothing just to be neutral and you say
it's very difficult for him you know and
and is it was difficult for me for you
know you say that there's no casting
disgusting a clay is casting disgusting
you know is there's no casting you
cannot feel the soul behind clay
figurine so to cast them and each flavor
Green is unique we are not a factory you
know yeah I have I have only one school
tour for a hundred figurine only one guy
I walk seven day a week and each
sequence how we have to talk about which
one will be at the front which one would
meet at the background and he's how it's
fair how how he must to express what is
the subject is very difficult and each
figurine is unique and after that maybe
you know if the figurine is how it's
done existing you cannot put the voice
you cannot put the score you cannot put
everything you know it cannot work so
the first thing is a figurine is a maybe
we are lucky because in our culture when
we pray a father I'm probably pray
before the Buddha statue we do not pray
the clay or the stone we pray the spirit
after behind the Buddha when two Buddha
come here he will go to museum he's
become art but maybe he'll anymore
spirit but in Cambodia you have two
spirit everywhere in the mountain in the
river in each statue so when we maybe
it's helped us to it helps us cool tour
to to produce his it's figurine
that that's fascinating because you're
absolutely right each figurine has its
own its own personality without it's
moving with it what's being said about
it how its how its rest the expression
on its face and in the situation in
which it's done there's a sometimes it
doesn't entirely work when you see
behind the scenes but it's actually very
very I think fascinating and your end
credits when we see your studio and we
get an idea of how everything was
created and sure it's very small you
know like this one but at the end I have
my bed my studio my figurine everything
of it with me you know in the same room
sometimes the affinity shoot at six
o'clock and I start editing until 4:00
in the morning when we walk like that
and at the end like I live and I sleep
just next to my figurine you know it's
like these people is like there we are
talking with them every day I I cannot
really a try you know I try I try
I fight to try to forget everything
first but it's not possible so now I
have to deal with to delete it's mean
that I still talking with those who died
and office just to to try to give them
back their dignity by making each him if
I did I did not know the genocide maybe
I will not be here probably I will teach
I like teaching I like school I like so
I come to cinema because of this tragic
story but I learned day by day too low
you know maybe maybe at the end of my
life I will make musical comedy it's
mean that I feel better well you heard
Gavin you should come to Hollywood
Thomas obviously you have a huge star
and you're in your film and I'm assuming
most of the other actors because I
recognize several of them are obviously
professional actors did you use any any
people from the from where you were
shooting was at all pretty much a
regular casting of bonafide actors and
how in the world did you find the little
girl who played Clara who is just
looking at this clip again I'm reminded
of how expressive she is and when the
hurt she feels without showing any sort
of tried child hurt when she's rebuffed
by her by her friend and teacher well
first of all I was told never to work
with children or animals and in fact it
was it paid off really well
they're nice to work with they don't ask
questions you ask them to bark and they
do no offence max it's it's a walk in
the park I can recommend it but no
obviously I've always had the desire to
work with Mads Mikkelsen I just wanted
the right part for him and the rest of
the cast are many of them are my friends
small country people have worked with
before I do my process is very often
trying to write for specific actors I to
put them in places where where I think
they should should be and but in case of
this little girl we we have this
brilliant casting director who's old who
was also coaching her throughout the
film and and she was just amazing it's
she was just really good and she could
digest everything I said and she could
digest it as a grown-up and
how much did you you let her know well
we had to let her know that people were
angry with her and that she had lied but
of course we could not confront her with
anything sexual she so for those of you
who haven't seen the film the little
girl
sees at one point a glimpse on her
brother's iPad a pornographic image
which sees then somehow internalizes and
and is affected by the scene we just saw
when she she makes it makes a a casual
statement but she has just a little bit
of this information she got from her
brother's iPad that gives it a certain
reality and obviously with a bit of
editing we avoided her being confronted
with that iPad and stuff but but you
know she was just brilliant yeah the the
crew would start spontaneously
applauding her after it take she was
just she just wiped the floor and and
mats was fairly intimidated when the
camera turned to him
isn't that right up against the dark and
innocent child all the time so no that
was a brilliant experience and and she
enjoyed it she enjoyed the applause and
she enjoyed it like a bit of a sports
game so she very rapidly became really
really good and learned from this and
braised it and it doesn't want to be an
actress she's not a not spoiled and I
think she wants to do ping pong has she
seen the film yes she's seen the film
thought it was fine I think that's how
it is I think there are other films she
would rather see you know
Paulo you've now worked with with your
lead actor four times right on four
films one of the most astonishing
reviews one of the great reviews of your
film and certainly in the English
language came from The New Yorker not
not too long ago and and the review is
almost half of it is about I think it's
romantic mean like I think about half of
it is about Toni Sevilla having one of
the great faces of all time faces of
cinema and I think it's absolutely true
and so I'm assuming when you wrote this
you knew he was going to play Jeb the
rest of the rest of the casting process
is it
are these actors you normally work with
or sometimes agree about and I choose
chooses the doctors following two prints
two ideas
the first was that since the set
shooting is very boring the best thing
was to get Fanny actors so I I choose
mostly funny actors like Carlucci Russo
carlo verdone Sabrina fiddly yeah for
Antonio Sevilla is the fan is to also it
was for me a good idea to work with him
and then we'd visit four movies together
and that kind of character was perfect
for him I recognized the soon the kind
of character and the other idea was to
choose actors that like he said the last
questions possible before because but
not because I am NOT able to do not not
because I don't want to dancer but
because before shooting I don't ever
answer so I start to advance with only
after the second the third to take and
before if the people give two questions
I appear like a stupid and I don't like
which which take two you usually use the
first the second the third the fourth
often the last one the last one is the
best yeah if the last one is the six
seven eight and n do you let them read
the whole script the actors yes yes yes
yes before because if they read the
script I have more chance to not receive
them any questions
because though some answers are in the
in the script so I give to everybody the
script if they decide to read the script
and and then I'm assuming you don't do a
rehearsal process no no no no not
because at the beginning of the first
movies I have done I did many rehearsals
but then when we arrived on the on the
stage and set after too many really also
I found that the actors were a little
bit tired no they were not able to give
too many surprised so now I prefer to
not to rehearsal and so it's more
exciting on the set for me and for them
to to find out what happened
you also have an enormous cast in this
in this film and and you know a little
bit of everybody in star in fact now I
think about at the start of the movie I
think is some a bunch of Japanese
tourists right that and and by the way
and in the opening of the film night I
only understood I think on this third
viewing because I thought what exactly
does this this this tourist who
collapses well what exactly is his
relevance and I even know if you heard
me say I'm a huge fan of the film and I
thought there's my family that I didn't
fit it in I'm assuming he's reacting to
the beauty of Rome and is basically
collapsing that I'm assuming yes but if
I had to say the truth I think that the
beginning of a movie must be something
of the strong and ambiguous so you can
ask what happened at the beginning so I
don't know exactly why he dies yes the
beauty of Rome it's funny we're in the
lobby and a friend of mine just just as
mad who who shot him at the end of the
hunt and he said you know the answer is
all of us or my props manager you can
peek perfect honey but what about you
your you have a annex very experienced
actor who lives in the in the US it was
also your producer one of your producers
and we've seen him in a number of movies
and on stage in New York but then
surrounded by a very not only an
experience that I'm assumed mostly
first-time actors is that right yes and
indeed like well it was easy cast
because knew him and he's
dr. experienced actor but the others
it's normal like it way I there is a
casting director of Jerusalem and she
asked everybody to put himself on tapes
I auditions a lot a lot of people at the
end we end up with Adam who actually
just finished Lee Strasberg School in
New York and he become the lead actor
than the lemes she was 16 at that time
never acted before and its first movie
he had is a theatre actor never acted in
that film before and salmon is also 16
was in a short movie before but this is
his first feature from and what was it a
long process well he lives in LA Adam
now lives in New York Lima and summer in
Nazareth and and he had in Ramallah oh
my gosh and and and and so you had one
casting director fine fine find all of
them and and since they didn't have
agents was it a process of going to two
schools agents wrong agent so is it
going going to school to find actors who
I think we like the casting director
find Liam on internet I think through
her sister actually she asked her sister
to audition her sister was in Italy and
she told her why you don't ask my sister
I think your sisters also here well this
is how to our girls like it's you know
through Facebook through advertisement
through knowing people you audition like
we audition more than 200 people and
then you choose just five it's normal
casting process I have no juicy stories
about
and and do you shoot pretty much the
script or do you allow a lot of improv
for instance where did where the brand
they'll come from and the only actually
the only improvised or let's say I
adapted from an actor was the Brando
joke because I knew like Amgen has to
make a joke there because he will be the
funny guy the comic relief and there was
a in the script was a longer like he
will tell a joke but then when I saw him
one one morning and on the breakfast he
was doing Brando and I felt this is
better than the whole job because this
is life and this is how I adapted that
Brando imitation to the script
but the rest was pretty the same like
all of the other things were written
during the four days of panic so an Omar
open just opened on last last Friday in
the u.s. is that right yes it's playing
in 50 theaters in the US adopt film
distributed they are so happy with it
and I think 50 screens they are for us
huge
I mean I'm thank them for doing that
and and no surprise to spectacular
reviews and then Paulo your film I
noticed his plane across the street
how long ago how long ago did it it
opened in the u.s. it opened in October
or November I don't remember exactly but
to choose him a long time ago yeah
October October and November no I'm
sorry I was optimistic and and then it
then it played throughout the summer in
this last summer and in Italy yes in
Italy was released in May of the last
year
soon after the Cannes Film Festival
right and I'm assuming it was a huge
huge hit now in Italy yes yes it was
when people don't love something they
run to see and then Thomas the hunt
opened in the US some time ago and in
fact it's probably already available on
on DVD and in it's on Netflix and DVD
and but reopened you're in Los Angeles
for some reason not long ago and yeah
but it opened in all the way this is
this is a long journey it started in can
12 and then it opened in January 13 in
Denmark and became a massive box office
success tiny country though but but
which was a very big satisfaction for us
with this topic in all and that was
great and it was interesting because it
moved from the cultural pages into the
debate sections of the newspapers which
I think made it a bigger film yeah and
mads one one one can is a best actor
right and he shoot and he deserved it
yeah
obviously working working with a hyper
intelligent generous team player like
him is just a miracle and he deserves
all the praise he can get the lights are
low I hope he's still here we've been
talking about him a lot and then the
missing picture I notice it with Platt
was playing in one theater in in the
valley a couple of a couple of months
ago what has it where has it else has it
played in the in the US and with the
nomination is there any chance it will
get re-released in America I think that
did will come in three week in here in
New York but it's makuu makuu's who in
trend releasing Walker on that and I
hope that of scandal mean it will have
strange releasing to have more theater
it was released in Cambodia last year's
after cab festival and we will release
it again
in 6 March but no you know fee I was in
the street when people send me SMS to
tell me that you are know me 40 ask the
street in middle of the night in Phnom
Penh it has a little bit surprised and
and now few week later you have a group
of young people whose real website
Facebook something like that thousand
people now on Facebook to support and
I'm very happy because at the film it's
no it's not his belong to them to these
young people who were where after the
genocide to memory genocide they
appropriate the story
they proud to have they not proud about
the genocide but proud about
we are still here today you know it's
mean that we are alive that this
totalitarian regime cannot destroy us we
are here and it's very important for us
Felix broken circle breakdown when did
it opened it was not not long ago right
in the u.s. I mean November also October
November and then it was I think it
opened throughout the United States it
was released after we got nominated and
it's already available on iTunes and
beauty and and DVDs soon I guess and you
told me that you had it wasn't until the
Berlin Film Festival last year that it
really started to take on a life of its
own right yeah we because we released it
in Belgium six months prior to the
festival and it took a while for the
movie to find its way were turned down
by numerous festivals and we were like
maybe it's not gonna happen with this
movie maybe we were wrong although it
did very well in Belgium but we thought
maybe people think this is just strange
Belgians playing bluegrass which it is
but then we went to Berlin were very
fortunate to get selected in the
panorama section and it was the most
incredible premiere that we could have
had and it it sold all over the world
there and we've been travelling with the
movie since and you just won the say
sorry yesterday right for that best best
foreign language film thank you
if if you haven't already do yourselves
a huge favor and go see these five films
one way or another thank you all very
much
thank you more